I want to talk about depressing things
the cost of eggs has surpassed the price
of beef eggs are more expensive than
beef right now I will get into that more
next week but that's an amazing
statistic
makes us feel like we're becoming a
third world country our trains don't run
we've got poison seeping out everywhere
we can't afford food people are
depressed the average life expectancy is
decreasing
because of deaths of Despair we don't
have a functioning border whatever we
are doing right now we always want to
project our power overseas and say we're
going to solve all the world's problems
and we need to go spread democracy
around the world or whatever how about
we spread a flourishing Society here at
home
We are Becoming like a third world
country